hey this is presh talwalkar
there are 25 horses
what is the minimum number of races
needed so you can identify the fastest
three horses
you can race up to five horses at a time
you do not have a watch
this problem is sometimes asked as a
technical interview question at
companies like google
but since it is a little bit vague let
me present another version which has
some details that allow you to solve the
problem
there are 25 mechanical horses and a
single race track
each horse completes the track in a
pre-programmed time
and the horses all have different
finishing times unknown to you
you can race up to five horses at a time
after a race is over you get a printout
with the order the horses finished but
not the finishing times of the horses
what is the minimum number of races you
need to identify the fastest three of
all the horses
i was suggested this problem by email
from the puzzle maker terry stickles and
it is sometimes asked as an interview
question at companies like google
so can you figure it out
pause the video right now and give it a
try
when you're ready keep watching the
video for a solution
the answer is you can find the three
fastest horses in a minimum of seven
races
i will first describe the procedure in
words and then i will go over the
solution in detail so that you
understand why it works
the first step is to divide the 25
horses into groups of five and race the
horses in each group
this will be a set of five races
next take the winner from each group and
race those five horses
the winner of this race which is the
winner of the winners is the fastest
horse overall
now in order to get the second and third
fastest horses we're going to have to do
one more race
but to describe that race i'm going to
have to present some notation
so label the five groups from step one
as a b c d and e
to correspond to the groups for the
horses that finished in first second
third fourth and fifth place for the
race in step two in other words label
the groups in step one according to the
results of the winners race in step two
furthermore write a subscript to
identify the order that the horse
finished within a group
so a2 means the horse that finished
second place in group a
so here's that final race
we do one more race with a2 a3 b1 b2 and
c1
that is race the second and third
fastest horses from group a
the fastest and second fastest horses
from group b and the fastest horse from
group
c the top two finishers in this race
will be the second and third fastest
horses overall
so now i'm going to show you this
procedure in detail and explain why it
is the correct procedure
so we start out by dividing the 25
horses into groups of five
in this race we have a race of five
horses and i'm going to illustrate it so
that the slowest horse is on the left
and the fastest horse is on the right
i'll rearrange the horses if necessary
so that it follows that the slowest
horse is on the left and the fastest
horses on the right
i'll do this for all the horses and all
of the different groups
now we are going to take the winner from
each group and race those five horses
this will be the horse on the far right
hand side of each group
the winner of this race which will be
the winner of the winners will then be
the fastest horse overall
i am again going to draw this so that
the slowest of the winners is on the
bottom and the fastest of the winners is
on the top
we'll rearrange the groups as necessary
to make this diagram work
so now we have the fastest of the
winners
this will be the fastest horse overall
we know that it's beat every other horse
within its group and it's beat the
fastest horse in every other group so we
have identified the fastest horse
overall
now in order to get to the second and
third fastest horses will have to
identify the different groups
so we have the fastest group being a and
the slowest group being e
so how are we going to get the second
and third fastest overall
we're going to do this by process of
elimination
we can eliminate any horse that is
slower than at least three other horses
if a horse is slower than at least three
other horses there's no way it could be
the second or third fastest overall
so to start out with we can eliminate
all the horses in group e
every single horse in this group will be
slower than the fastest horses in groups
a b and c this is because the fastest
horse was slower than the fastest horses
in these groups a b and c
so all of the horses in groups in group
e cannot possibly be
the second or third fastest overall
for exactly the same reason we can
eliminate all horses in group d
all of them are slower than a1 b1 and
c1 we can continue this logic and we can
eliminate all the horses in group c
except for the fastest horse
all of these other horses will be slower
than a1 b1 and c1
now in group b we can eliminate all the
horses except for the two fastest horses
b1 and b2
all of them will again be slower than a1
b1 and then b2
so the horses in third fourth and fifth
place in group b
can be eliminated
from group a we can eliminate the fifth
and fourth fastest horses because they
will be slower than the top three horses
within their own group
we're left with six horses we can only
race five at a time but we can actually
get rid of one of these horses
we've already identified the fastest
horse overall a1 so we don't need to
erase it anymore we already know it's
the fastest overall we can't learn any
more information by racing it
so we can actually remove this horse
from our race
so we now have a2 a3 b1 b2 and c1 and we
do not know the relative speeds of these
different horses
so we can do one more race with these
five horses
the winner of this race will be the
second fastest horse overall and the
runner-up will then be the third fastest
overall
so these will be seven races which will
allow us to identify the three fastest
horses
now just a quick note
we've shown that seven races is
sufficient i just want to explain why
it's minimal
we obviously have to race each of the 25
horses once
and since we can race five horses at a
time that means we're going to at least
start out with 25 over 5 which is 5
races
we're then going to need to compare the
winners which will be one more race
and we're then going to have to compare
at least the second place from group a
to the fastest horse in group b amongst
other possible comparisons in order to
find out the second fastest horse
so we know at least seven races will be
needed and we've shown seven races is
sufficient therefore the described
procedure is optimal
did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description